there's a debate on Twitter Cristiano
Ronaldo versus Beyonce basically this
girl said that Beyonce had more Global
influence than Cristiano Ronaldo we're
not talking about who's more famous yeah
we're talking about who's more
influential is there something specific
that he does in soccer that makes you
want to play like that he came out with
like a flash in this like he made an
entire like soccer cleat like the
Mercurial Vapor everyone saw it was like
I want that because Ronaldo wears those
but that's not input like Steph Curry is
way more influential than LeBron it's
not even a question staff has changed
the way that every player plays game
basketball when I see a guy like Neymar
who's got all this crazy footwork I
would say though that Neymar was
inspired by Ronaldo he's like kind of a
branch from his tree even the
celebration everyone does the the silly
[ __ ] in the UFC yeah like they do it
everywhere wasn't Beyonce the first one
to do the unannounced album drop just
all at once in the middle of the night
very true Beyonce became like an
archetype of a person that you want to
Aspire to be that influence to women was
there too gay men was there I mean she
was like super influential to uh dick
lovers
all over the world